[Ukraїner
Експедиція]
[Поділля,
Василівка]
Це в нас тут ростуть огірки,
також горіхи мікоризовані,
які ми дорощуємо для того,
щоб їх висадити на осінь вже на відкритий ґрунт
для горіхового саду з трюфелем.
Якщо дати папуасу IPhone,
[Олександр Джига
Фермер]
він почне його використовувати
як дзеркальце, або цвяхи ним забивати.
Так само і ми з трюфелем.
Поки ми не знали, що це трюфель,
ми його просто варили.
Вважали, що він трішки кращий,
аніж білий гриб.
Бо він хрумкіший й ароматніший.
Ми знали, що це гриб «волове серце».
Також його ще називають «Крумплі»
в деяких селах.
Я от зустрічав друзів з Миколаєва,
вони приїхали й під дорогою кажуть:
«Візьмімо грибів білих сушених».
Дивлюся, а в банках закатаний
чорний літній трюфель.
Я питаю: «А це що за гриби?».
«А це крумплі». Я кажу:
«Скільки вони коштують?»
Каже: «Наполовину дешевше,
ніж білі гриби, бо ніхто не купляє.
Вони їстівні, не бійтесь, не отруїтесь».
[сміється]
Я кажу: «Добре, давайте».
Люди просто не знають.
Я ж кажу, папуаси.
Тут ми побачимо псевдотрюфель.
Як відрізнити трюфель від
псевдотрюфеля?
Беремо, як французи роблять.
І тепер, коли вириваєте трюфель,
ви бачите мікоризу.
Ось ці волоски — це корені гриба.
У нашому разі, якби це був справжній
трюфель, цієї мікоризи, тобто корінчика, не було б.
Дивимося, справді як корінчик,
якщо його потрушу, ну як корінчик.
Уявіть, якщо це трюфель, то ці корінчики
обволікають повністю корінь дерева,
і збільшують площу у
багато-багато разів.
Це не трюфель, а порхавка,
можна так сказати.
Ще його «оленячий трюфель»,
«дощовик» називають.
Ось це розлітаються спори гриба,
які так, як і в трюфеля,
всередині плодового тіла закриті.
Ці спори...
Цей гриб теж їстівний,
коли він не перестиглий.
І якщо ви поранились десь,
то можете протерти — ці спори, як антибіотики.
Через те, що в час,
коли спори проростають,
вони виділяють антибіотики для того,
щоб вбити конкурентів.
У мене товариш займається
біопрепаратами.
Він мікробіолог.
Він почав підкидати мені якісь
ідеї для бізнесу...
І от за трюфель каже: «Саша, ти чув,
є такий дорогий гриб, трюфель».
Я кажу: «Так, чув, з мене батько
завжди глузував у дитинстві».
Коли я не хотів щось їсти, він казав:
«Може тобі трюфеля в леопардовому соусі?»
Тобто батько теж про трюфеля чув,
але ми не розуміли.
А потім Володя каже:
«А як, в нас будуть рости?»
Кажу: «Клімат Франції
й України трохи подібні.
Культури дерева подібні.
Думаю, якщо створити
нормальні умови, то можна,
але де ми візьмемо насіння цього трюфеля,
спори або мікоризовані саджанці?»
У нас тоді ніяких зв’язків не було.
А потім він мені показує фотографію, я кажу:
«Володь, та це ж волове серце».
Він відповідає: «Та трюфель».
Я кажу: «Значить ми
його відрами збираємо».
Він каже: «Все, Сань, якщо тепер
хтось глузуватиме з тебе, ти кажи:
"Що ти мені розказуєш,
я трюфелі відрами їм"».
[сміється]
Для трюфеля повинно бути сонце.
Ті плантації, де не зімкнулися крони дерев,
то там трюфель і залишився,
а де зімкнули, то там трюфель
не плодоносить.
Тобто для того, щоб він утворював
плодові тіла, потрібно сонце.
І тому в інтенсивних трюфельних плантаціях
формують певним чином дерева,
щоб світло проникало.
Густіше дерева садять, щоб швидше
обплести територію мікоризою.
Але тоді треба їх обрізати,
треба по колу
обертати корені,
тобто фризувати по колу.
Ось ще одна ознака того,
що це трюфель.
Якщо ми бачимо, що кабани
або козулі починають рити землю,
це ознака того, що
там може бути трюфель.
Яким чином дивимося
чи це місце трюфельне чи ні?
Бачимо, що ця земля дуже суха,
що аж не можу.
Я колупаю і дивлюсь:
якщо є мікориза, білий пушок,
то значить це місце, де можна колупати,
можливо, кабан щось упустив.
[сміється]
Тут нічого немає, можливо,
мишей чи ще щось ловили.
Коли вже взнали ціну трюфеля,
зразу помінялося ставлення.
Мене в цьому році запитали:
«А ти трюфель у цьому році їв?»
Кажу: «Так, один раз їв, бо гості приїхали,
треба було пригостити».
[сміється]
А так якось тримаєш у руці і думаєш:
поїсти трюфеля чи заробити для того,
щоб у плантацію  закласти,
бо плантація є досить недешевою справою.
Ми хочемо узаконити саме
сертифіковані саджанці,
щоб була ліцензія,
генетичний паспорт.
Щоб ми працювали нормально,
могли експортувати та офіційно продавати.
Літній трюфель занесений до Червоної книги,
чорний літній трюфель.
І щоб у нас можливість була,
щоб нам ніхто не дорікав, що це вид, який вимирає.
Ми навпаки його хочемо відновити,
щоб у нього було майбутнє
в Україні в більших масштабах.
Намагаємось кожну копійку зекономити,
тому трюфелі торік один раз тільки їв.
Бачите, така біла ниточка,
вони просто зісохлися зараз.
Бачите, біла от, бачите?
Оце бачите?
Оце якраз мікориза.
Бачите, вона так тримається
ніби земля купи,
а от корінчик цей коричневий — це корінь дерева.
Так, звісно, не варто робити,
але бачите от білий такий пушок.
Якщо брати трюфель, то не скажеш,
де низ, а де верх.
У ньому нема цих корінців, він повністю
весь такий, з формою такою негарною,
а якщо брати чорний трюфель,
то він такий гарний, як якась шишка така.
Як я говорив, трюфель росте кублами,
зазвичай це називають «гніздом».
Що глибше трюфель,
то він більший.
І ми бачимо, що ми якраз цей
викопали, він був найглибший.
Ці трюфелі – це білий трюфель, він охороняється
бойовими василівськими комарами.
[сміється]
Тому тут небезпечно самому
ходити без мене.
Завжди є, поки сам до кінця не попробував,
якась невіра в те, що не може бути такої халяви.
[сміється]
Не може бути трюфелів.
Я коли на першій конференції виступав,
сиділи мікробіологи, мікологи з університетів,
які все життя займаються
вивченням грибів,
які знають багато, значно
більше, ніж я.
І коли я почав розповідати
про власний досвід, вони казали:
«цього не може бути», «так не робиться»,
«це не може бути», «в мікології не так».
Я відповів: «Скажіть трюфелям,
що це не так. Бо ж ростуть.»
Що там росте, що там
один і той самий вид.
Я дивлюсь, які є закономірності,
що йому підходить, а що, можливо, ні.
Ну і так вивів для себе
формулу ідеального ґрунту для трюфеля.
[Автор проєкту
Богдан Логвиненко]
[Оператори
Павло Пашко, Андрій Рогозін]
[Продюсерка
Оля Шор]
[Режисер
Микола Носок]
[Музика
Endless Melancholy]
[Ukraїner
Експедиція]